[Music]
are you seeing alliances being created
the russia china connection got stronger
a lot of that was because of the oil
relationship
you want us to do business with china
we'll open up tick tock but you got to
open up facebook twitter all this other
stuff the hilton in shanghai
you can actually get on facebook and you
can actually google things which i would
not have known had i not physically
been there do you think the fed did more
good or bad to america
we don't have free markets anymore
that's kind of like saying basil's
buffett kids these guys make all the
decisions in the world
i believe in fair capitalism what is the
alternative bill i also believe in
democratic socialism
if america were to go back to gold
standard who would be against it
wall street the banking community it
makes sense have you ever seen america
as divided as we are today
i have not seen it this tense how close
are we to civil war
on the streets or in the markets
so i have an interesting guest with me
today i have nomi prince
i want to say the last name right nomi
prince with me a guest that say
got a lot to talk about when it comes
down to the economy she used to work two
years
as a managing director at goldman sachs
and she was there on the 29th floor
when 9 11 happened and plane flew right
by her corner office at goldman sachs if
you've got a corner office
you got a corner office i mean that's
where you want to be when you're working
at a place like that
she was a senior managing director at
bear stearns for seven years
senior strategist at lehman's brothers
analyst at chase manhattan bank i mean i
can go on and on
got her bachelor's in mathematics my
kind of a person
uh then she got a minor in music and
masters in science and statistic
from nyu she's written multiple books uh
one of them being collusion how central
bankers rate the world in 2018
when the book came out and the other one
is all the president's bankers
with that being said nome prince thank
you so much for being a guest on
valuetainment
yeah thanks so much a pleasure it's good
to have you on so
first question i'm going to start off
with a soft question for you so we can
kind of get to know each other
how close are we to civil war
on the streets or in the markets give me
both
well you know here's the thing over the
last um
10 11 years since the financial crisis
and then you add on to that this
pandemic
we've reawakened the economic
instability that's inherent to
many many components of the economy and
the population
right so when you mix economic
instability with crisis
with inherent problems that exist
whether it be social tensions racial
tensions economic inequality
and you mix that all together you you
have a very perilous situation
and if you put on top of that the fact
that markets and the financial assets
side of the equation has been helped by
so much um compared to the actual people
part of this equation
um then we are close we're not even
close we are in the period of civil
unrest throughout a lot of the world
including
um what we've seen recently in the u.s
but we're also at
a point um and i call it a sort of
permanent distortion
between what's happening on the
financial economy side
in terms of also how it is helped and
subsidized versus what's happening on
the real or the foundational economy
side the small businesses the
individuals
and the things that they face um so so
that's where i think the civil
element and the economic element are
actually
very much part of the same thing
okay so you're saying we are there
we're not uh almost there we are there
but
do you think i mean maybe the question i
ask might be slightly different
have you ever seen america as divisive
as divided as we are today uh
yourself i mean you lived in new york
you lived in different places you've had
a lot of different experience you worked
at some of the most reputable companies
worldwide at
their peak people relied on them with
the decisions that they made
you ever seen america at a point where
people
are divided going at it the riots to
protesting do you ever see something
like this yourself
um no i mean i i think we're in a very
divisive um
point in in america's history at least
in the personal history that i've
experienced in in my
lifetime um because of these
kind of conjoining factors because of
the economy because of finances because
of
all the tensions that brings up and
because i think we are in a
in a very polarized um part of
uh us history i think the world to an
extent is is polarized in many places as
well and so there's there's a sort of
feeding
um between our country and other
countries and so forth around the world
but i think the fact that we have
um as much um sort of
instability on so many levels um of
individuals of the economy of of just of
races of
social elements and so forth i i have
not seen it
this this tense so therefore i've not
seen it this this bad the financial
crisis
a 2008 definitely opened up more
financial instability to a large swath
of of the population that's definitely
true
but but there wasn't as much of a sort
of tension
and a sort of almost push to
completely change um out of our
situation into something better for a
lot of people
and the tension on the other side of
others wanting to keep it exactly the
way it is
um and so that that tension i think is
really much
more apparent now um in the wake of this
pandemic
than it had been in the wake of the
financial crisis of 2008 or anything
that
that i have um experienced and i you
know
that includes the the wars that you know
the us has been in and the
demonstrations against those wars
demonstrations to reduce debt throughout
the world and so forth
this is this is more visceral this is
more spread out at the foundations
um of the country how much of this do
you think
is the media how much of it is china
trying to take over meaning of control
of power because there's a lot of moving
parts right now you got
pre-coronavirus we were talking brexit
we were talking china we were talking
tariffs we're talking venezuela we were
talking
saudi arabia oil iran a lot of different
things we were talking about
pre-coronavirus so
how much of its media how much of it's
china how much of it's coronavirus how
much of it do you think is
a trump and or anything else that i may
not be saying but there's got to be
something that's the tipping point
that's causing this what would you say
it is
i think there's there's there's a number
of things that you mentioned that kind
of come into play in sort of a pie type
of portion
right so and i'm glad you bring up um
sort of how the international community
the international
sort of globalized world was before the
coronavirus and now how it is
because a lot of it's the same right
there's more tension now there's more
uprising now but
a lot of the issues are are still there
for example
trade uncertainties between the us and
china the the sort of
battle between the us and china in terms
of who's gonna
um be the most legitimized superpower
um going forward that's gonna mark the
21st century we're still we're still in
the young part of a century
um and a lot of stuff has gone down in
terms of
money related crises during this century
but the result has been a lot of
um isolationism you know sort of a new
form of
populism a new form of you sort of
tariff controls and battles from from
that element of economics
um and i think that's going to be um
ongoing to an extent the
the china um leveraged a lot of what
happened in the financial crisis of 2008
i i've analyzed this a lot and talked
about a lot and been there and so forth
um since the financial crisis um but
they basically
leveraged the situation where our
federal reserve the way the u.s whole
monetary system was
created and then moved into the new part
of this century
and all the sort of cheap money and the
asset buying all the programs
that the us began in the wake of the
financial crisis
um and they physically leveraged this to
do a number of things one is to get the
chinese currency the rent into the sdr
the security basket
of the imf so to become a more
legitimate currency
in terms of trade um and they openly use
that element
um when i say they i mean the the former
people's uh bank of china
had um in conjunction with the imf so
they were trying to sort of pivot their
power
um from the standpoint of our sort of
loose monetary system with their more
dedicated as they saw monetary system um
so while we were
using that money as a country to
basically invest ultimately in financial
assets the markets and so forth and they
did quite well as a result
um they were sort of using it to
build alliances with countries that had
been weakened um in the wake of the
financial crisis of 2008.
um and they did this with the brics
countries they you know they had the
alliance with brazil
grow substantially such that they became
the largest trading partner with brazil
relative to the us and so there was this
juxtaposition this fight that was going
on since the financial crisis between
um these two superpowers and now you
bring in um
years of that into the coronavirus
pandemic um and
and there's still a lot of obvious
tension in that relationship
um but we're in a situation now where uh
china had the virus sort of first and
and and sort of got over it you know
there's still cases beijing is still
closing in parts but sort of
and the us is still sort of grappling
with what that's going to look like over
the number of months
and so china is able to kind of um
resurrect that that sort of power
position
but they're also doing it in a way where
they're containing hong kong and they're
sort of
annoying a lot of the trade partners
that they've developed over these last
12 years
um and so that could mean a pendulum
switch back to
the us but yet we're in a weakened point
of our economy
so i i think that pendulum swing between
those two superpowers and how countries
um get sort of caught up in between that
um it is actually a major
point of general um economic um
tension in the world outside of where it
relates to like
the individual to the population to to
issues that people small businesses
individuals are dealing with on a
day-to-day basis
so i do think that's that's a big
component um of where we are here
because all the dominoes sort of fall
around that
from a large economical standpoint and
then you go down from multinational
companies using both countries to middle
to smaller to a supply chain to
small businesses and and there's a lot
going on back and forth
behind the scenes of every day life for
you know real people
you know typically when conflicts happen
like this what we're experiencing that's
global uh some
relationships obviously uh uh deter
and there's a fallen out and then an
enemy of an enemy becomes a
friend so people that weren't allies
they become allies and
so in this situation are you seeing
russia iran and china get closer and are
you seeing
iran uh us uk and
india get closer in this because you
know
india is coming up you just heard
china's investing a few hundred billion
dollars in iran which
obviously asia relies on the middle east
for oil 76 percent or oil comes from
iran
in the middle east are you seeing
alliances being created
and if yes who got stronger who got
weaker
um so that's interesting as well so the
the russia china um
connection of it got stronger in in the
wake of the financial crisis
into today and a lot of it was because
and you throw iran into that more recent
a lot of that was because of
the oil relationship china is you know
majorly growing population
um they have turned to invest in their
new sort of five-year plans in green
infrastructure sustainability fast
trains and so forth
but they are reliant still on wanting to
have an independent supply of oil
um and that's one of the sort of pivots
that they've made to sort of find
stronger alliances create and establish
and grow
stronger alliances where that can be the
case um
the the relationship between china and
russia into into this period has also
been one of the currency relationship
um they they have agreed to effectively
transact
in each other's currency along the way
and that's a way
of kind of moving that from um
dollar-denominated
base trade or or the old
petrodollar-based trade that sort of
evolved out of the 70s um
and into today it was a way to sort of
combat that
so yes that has been one element of
strength in terms of alliances
um china had also strengthened their
alliances in sort of the asian region um
in the smaller countries um and they had
actually had more conversations until
kind of recently that went quite well
uh with japan who had been an old
adversary of china
in order to sort of solidify their
alliances and
and create a lot of sort of commissions
and sort of new
um agreements um between china and japan
into this particular peer
period um there hasn't been anything new
in the last sort of
year-ish uh and there's also been more
tension because of the south china sea
and other things going on in that
area but so so there's been a sort of
back and forth in terms of the u.s
um and the uk and the uk
and the eu and the eu and china there's
a lot of moving parts
in that i think with the uk um how
brexit will ultimately
look in terms of agreements relative to
the eu is going to give us more clarity
on what happens
relative to the us because what's gone
on in this six month period
as the uk and the us have been dealing
with the virus
you know three to however this this
lasts um
the uk had for a while kind of forgot
about their brexit
conversations because they were dealing
with what was on the ground which was
the virus
same thing with the u.s so conversations
between them had kind of taken a little
bit of a back burner in terms of how
trade agreements would look
i think that's going to step up i think
that relationship which has kind of not
really gone anywhere very recently
is going to step up and i think that
china is going to have issues between
the uk and hong kong hong kong
and china china and the eu which are
going to make
that whole arrangement um from stanford
to trade diplomacy um and
power um a little bit looser than it
might otherwise have been
weaker than it otherwise might have been
you think china trusts
russia well let me ask you in a
different way you think russia trusts
china more than they trust u.s um i
i think russia would be trying to
get what they can out of both sides i
agree
i i don't know i don't know that it's
necessary a trust issue it's it's a
pragmatic
um issue i think that they would be
trying to they are trying to balance
i'm just i'm just wondering if they're
if they're trying to use capitalize off
the opportunity right now that there's
division between
us and china to get in there and say hey
let's uh
make our power plays because i the the
one thing china and russia has in common
right now it seems like they both want
to capitalize off of iran which is weak
right now with the sanctions and the
people there the economy is not good
people are afraid and
the folks of power want to keep the
power that's right and
maybe both china and russia are saying
let's try to capitalize we don't care
about being good with america but let's
just try to at least take advantage of
oil that's there
with uh the challenges that's taking
place but do you think
are we getting to a point like do you
remember when china was
number seven economy gdp and it wasn't
like at the top and
nobody really looked at china as
anything crazy
we just kind of knew china was there and
and when i'm saying this i'm saying 30
years ago 25 years ago
it's been a couple decades ago right and
then all of a sudden they did the
olympics
and the opening to the olympics which
was incredible i was like wait a minute
that's the best opening olympic show
i've seen
do you think india is getting close to
the point where they can compete
for the top spot or do you think they're
decades away from being there
that's really interesting because the
the period that you mentioned in china
how it used to be um so my first
big international kind of banking trip
um was to well basically china hong kong
philippines malaysia that region
um we did a kind of central bank trip me
and um a couple people from lehman who
are working on some products and so that
was kind of my first
international foray because lehman
brothers wanted to have more treasury
government bonds sold into the chinese
central bank at the time and so
relationships was just sort of
uh being created and and there was a
power play on wall street as to who
would
basically become the people's bank of
china's the central bank of china's
you know partner um and so that was one
of the first trips that that i went on
um and at the time you know streets of
beijing were like obviously a long time
ago
um but the streets of beijing were just
you know full of um
you know no outside westerners or
very very few and we were we were very
very um
unique in that respect um and i remember
at the time the whole the whole story
was well this is going to open like
china is going to open it's going to be
a big thing
it's it's central banks can get involved
it's it's monetary um
you know sort of authorities are going
to get involved and it's going to be the
next big thing and
it took um decades
for it to really become that from an
international perspective
but it's not like it wasn't doing it
then it was just on a very sort of back
burn nobody's really paying attention
unless you were in it kind of thing um
so with respect to india
um they're ahead of that position
because they have been part of the brics
because they have created
you know the ndp the national
development bank which is kind of this
idea that there would be an imf
or um world bank equivalent to the west
um that was sort of run by these five
major nations
and so they have been um and they have
obviously a lot of
technological advance they have a strong
population they're trying to work
um towards becoming that superpower i i
don't think yet um they're at the level
where they're
that sort of challenge um i i would say
maybe are a decade decade and a half
behind um china not that they're not
growing
but but to sort of if you if you think
of the world as having three superpowers
let's say
um as opposed to two which really we
have
um i i think we're we're about at that
trajectory
um it could accelerate but but that's
that's kind of what's going on so it's a
growing trajectory but there's a lot of
competition
um right from the two big powers and
everyone who's trying to stack
themselves in between
um as well while um india is trying to
to promote itself to elevate itself i
should say
do you think uh coronavirus uh uh
and the stories and the speculation that
you know whether
china released it or not bio warfare
warfare whatever you want to call it
some say it came out some say it's not
let's not debate that because neither
one of us are doctors to talk about that
but i'm just saying
do you think that story hurt
other countries trusting doing business
with china they kind of distanced
themselves a little bit from china
started looking at other places
where that could potentially benefit the
people of india where
folks may say look i i kind of trust
india they have a university called
iit they develop incredible engineers
they
seem to be better than mit on a lot of
different you know scores that i look at
and
i remember being in uh india i don't
know when it was when we went to india
and we were there with the chairman of
uh
state bank of uh uh was it 2018 or 2019
we were there at an iit on 5 000
engineers myself and
uh the chairman of state bank of india
arundhati bachchari this woman is a
leader amongst leaders she was on the
forbes top 20 most powerful women around
the world
240 000 employees and she said you know
india writes the most life insurance in
the world i'm like come on
she says no we have the most life
insurance policy holder i said what's
the data
316 million people in china in india
have life in
360. she says yes i said huh what what's
happening with india she says just watch
india is going to come up so do you
think the event of coronavirus
hurt others wanting to do business with
china
and it benefited india to come up
because more countries trust india than
they do china
i think there's two things on that i do
think that that trust
um from from the sort of multinational
business community
um relates into how where they say is
they where they see stability so whether
or not they trust that china
did or didn't or something happen that
we don't know about or or whatever with
respect to the virus
um i think the sort of result of that
um would be wanting to do more
diversification of their business and
india
for all the reasons you mentioned and
also the fact that it has an open
society from the standpoint of
information flow
um so if you look at all of that
together there's more of a sort of um
democratic
release of of information um
within india and then from india to the
outside world and i think that actually
um is the is that pivot is it is why
india is therefore also more attractive
aside from
the growth aside from the technology
aside from the minds aside from the size
aside from the desire is also that it
has more of an openness
within itself and i think that's
something that other countries can
relate to
um a lot better so i think with respect
to china that
whatever has gone on or not gone on with
respect to the virus
um it's it's more indicative of of the
sort of uh nature that other countries
can have relative to
to be more suspicious of china simply
because in general
um they don't allow the same level of
communication flow amongst their people
obviously with what's happening in hong
kong um and also
for international people who are working
or
traveling in and out of china um or will
be once you know all the barriers are
sort of
lifted um throughout the world in terms
of coronavirus bands but but i think
that's that's an issue that is at the
core that transparency issue that that
freedom of of communication issue which
is
what surrounds whatever happened with
coronavirus i think that's something
that countries and companies
um do very much consider yeah because
you know when you think about um
uh superpower military-wise you don't
think india
you don't think about india as somebody
that wants to go to war and wants to go
when you think about superpower you
think about nuclear you think about
russia you think about
u.s you think about you know certain
superpowers india doesn't come
indian comes across as wanting to be
more collaborative
to work with and you're talking about a
1.4 billion whatever the population is
give or take i mean that's not a
they're focused on education and you
know it's coming up
their their prime minister is a strong
individual who believes in capitalism
and innovation so
it's very interesting to see what's
going to happen there with them but
you know i sit down with different
people and i always
watch their reaction on how they feel
about china and i'm curious to know what
you're going to say
when i talk to ray daly about china he
has a different angle when i talk to
president bush about china a different
angle i talked to general spalding about
china
different angle some of them are we
don't trust them
at all some are very careful on what
they say about china
and it's almost like they're
uncomfortable because they have business
dealings
how do you feel about china and how do
you view china yourself
well i mean i don't have business
dealings with china myself so i'll just
throw that out there but um
i i studied for the last um
well since the financial crisis in
particular i mean aside from you know i
mentioned
i've been in china back and forth for
decades but um
as i have lots of places in the world
but um
what i what i specifically look at is
the kind of
um public communication that happens
between the us
and china and and for my um angle of
expertise
the sort of central bank the sort of
monetary policy sort of initiatives
relative to currency
um that happened between the two
countries um and so
with respect to china um there was a lot
of um
and there still is talk of whether they
manipulate their currency or what have
you had better sort of trade
um positions and trade advantages and i
think um
any country really that that could would
um to an extent you know move their
currency up and down to help their own
uh position um and i think we've done
that from the standpoint of our
zero percent monetary policy and
the increase of the fed's balance sheet
china's done it from the standpoint of
moving their rates around
um and what they consider non-qe which
is
um you know moving money into their
economy or lending money to
to regional alliances so that they
become dependent
um on china and so i look at more of a
standpoint of how money's flowing around
and i don't really um
and and you can see from that
perspective that there are points where
china moved its money
externally in order to build that
strength build those alliances
and and then where they've kind of been
questioned
about over over playing that step over
reaching
their alliances because of their
military might um
so from the standpoint of monetary
policy
um i think that they have tried to come
into the world but at the
same you know in terms of the imf in
terms of trade
um but at the same time i think in terms
of their military might or their sort of
um
suppression of of what hong kong wants
to do and and sort of their their um
what they've done in the region
um i think that's a negative um i think
it's a negative for
for the region i think it's a negative
actually
for china and for the world it's a
negative for china and the world i i
think
if you're just just in terms of i mean
and it's not that you know
it's it's that if you have the ability
as
a country um to forge alliances
or or to leverage weaknesses with other
countries and let me talk
monetarily not militarily for a second
it's it's one thing to do that to take
advantage
of that and to grow and do that and
china has done that over the last 12
years um significantly
it's another thing to then overstep
your your sort of military might um the
u.s does this
also i mean it's this is what countries
do they become powerful
and there's there's this like moment
there's multiple moments
but along the way there are moments
where there's a choice to be made
whether sort of maintaining an economic
diplomatic um
alliance is the number one priority or
whether they're sort of overstepping
from a more
um yeah sort of bullying or sort of
militaristic
pivot and those things could be back and
forth and i think i think with respect
to
china um they've had this this run
um and now they're in this position
where they're overstepping
um their the growth in their power
effectively and i think that's going to
hurt
china and i think with respect to the us
that then
potentially becomes an opportunity
to the us because i think there are
lessons to be learned from using
monetary policy lending investment
um to push your alliances as opposed to
just let's say
investing in markets um so so i think i
think
the both of these superpowers do things
in different ways and do things in
different ways but
there are lessons on both sides before
we get into the fed because i think you
were kind of alluding to that which
we'll get to that here in a second
is how do you think uh president trump's
handled
the terrorists the the trade war with
china
how do you think that's been handled the
last 12 18 months
well i think one of the results of
the last 12 to 18 months is that you
know both countries are trading less
in general and with each other you know
so so so where
um we have less of a deficit in trade
relative to china because of the tariffs
it hasn't helped our overall trade
position in general
um because the whole overall world what
has been happening as tariffs
have been um in play have been sort of
the battlefield
is that economies have also weakened at
the same time
now you could argue as as you could well
i could argue
that economies have been destabilized
throughout the world us and china and
every country
around and in between because of the
uncertainty over tariffs
and i think the uncertainty over tariffs
we have them we don't have them
they're going to be in a particular part
of the industrial chain and a particular
part of the supply chain make very
difficult for certain businesses
um particularly the ones that rely on
physical things
like steel like aluminum versus say the
technology sectors which which don't
as much it's kind of separate separate
uh
element of trade relationships you know
more intellectual property and another
thing but the ones that
are moral and physical um things
soybeans agriculture and so forth
um it's it's harder for uh countries
but specifically the businesses that are
running within those countries to plan
um as long as there's uncertainty over
tariffs
so i i think that the way in which um
tariffs have unfolded throughout the
world um
have led trade policy in general to be
viewed with
just tension and i think as a result of
that if we just take out the coronavirus
for just a second which is just
you know smash things right now further
we were looking at slowing gdp growth in
the u.s
that was happening throughout the world
as again not just because of these
tariffs or just because of trade but you
know
one is it's a cycle and one sort of
relies on each other uh and um and i
think that that's one of the things that
um
has been the negative of this particular
uh
tariff battle is that it's it's
it seems less planned and more reactive
on all sides really um then then
then sort of a more consistent trade
policy could be
that farmers that you know
in industrial engineers that use steel
and aluminum and build bridges or think
about
infrastructure planning um
[Music]
you know have have had to deal with yeah
i mean no
128 month expansion whatever the number
ones whether we hit 129 or 128
i mean that's the all time it's insane
to go that many months assuming it's
going to continue
right uh that's just not sustainable
right but uh
you know i i just what is the
alternative though
meaning when you're saying negotiating
with tariffs
uh when it happened it hurt a lot of
people both america and other countries
what is the alternative of not pushing
china that for decades none of the
presidents both on a left order right
has pushed china they just kind of
accepted the fact that a lot of these
tariffs have been in place
and we've said we're fine with it what
would be the alternative just leave it
the way it is
because whatever administration that
decides to go strong against china
whoever that president is that does it
they're going to have so many
opportunities
of it backfiring on them i mean there's
just so many opportunities
because you have four years to get it
done and if you take the four years take
one out because one of the years you're
going to be campaigning so you got three
years right
because that one year it's so painful so
and then take the first year out you
really have two years to get it done two
years is not enough to get something
done with china
to negotiate the tariffs and anybody who
takes that position
it's going to be disastrous for their
reputation it could be great it could be
bad so
what approach would you have taken if
you're sitting
trump calls you and says i want you to
be one of my advisors when it comes down
to the economy on dealing with china
what council
what advice would you give when dealing
with china on how to handle the tariffs
better than the way it was handled so so
first of all
the the way it was handled wasn't just
about china there was a lot of
of tariffs that popped out you know to
canada and to mexico and then to you and
then eu
but what happened was just just the way
of tariffs um became very sort of
um uh spotty and
shotgun approach just kind of like hey
just put a tear up i'm gonna do this i'm
not gonna do that no i'm gonna do this
i got it so so it it it isn't that
there weren't certain um products that
that that should be protected you know
on on
on our side and and that there are
things that we can negotiate
in terms of trade policy and in terms of
whether we call them tariffs or whether
we call them you know
required which kind of ultimately
happened in the phase one deal
um you know purchases to sort of equate
fairness amongst the variety of products
that we have so
you buy a certain amount of our
agriculture we'll do something else in
return
that kind of conversation um
in in a more fluid way um
and around the world again because it
wasn't just what was happening between
the us and china
there was a lot of u.s and other
countries um that
in which there were these conversations
going on as well and
and i think that had they been a little
more um
my suggestion would be to have those
conversations
be a bit more strategic and sort of
fluid
um from the get-go that isn't to say
that everyone does what they say
it's not to say every country is
trustworthy um it's not to say everybody
will do
what they promise to do however in the
basis of creating an agreement and a
trade policy
um i would look at what each you know
what what our partners
need and what we need from them i would
negotiate on on those components
mostly if i am looking at just looking
at trade policy
with china i would sort of ring fence
that and i would
try to make it um faced from the sort of
beginning
as opposed to i'm going to do these
tariffs to this date and if you don't do
this this is going to happen
and then this is going to happen and i
understand the nature of the of the sort
of
market part of that um but but what it
creates is a lot of instability in the
supply chain
all around that as well and that in
general
um has had i think had a deteriorating
effect
um so it's almost like i well almost
it's almost like that deteriorating
effect made it harder
to have the same impact of the trade
policy than
it otherwise could have been um so i
would have probably sat back
said take a breath take ten um
what do you actually want to accomplish
do you actually want to involve you know
wine from france or whatever like you
know what what's the actual focus here
focus um and and then look at a
multi-tier
potentially multi-phase agreement that
that works
that's interesting and by the way you
know a part of it is also style
you know on what his style is he's
scottish
real estate shotgun approach you're not
giving me that deal i'm going to take
this away from you i'm going to do this
i'm going to do that so it's uh well
that's the classic i walk away right
it's like you know you don't want this
deal
i leave the room you know you deal yeah
absolutely
but but but on a on a
international arena where
people from you know the person putting
you know gas into the tractor of the
farmer and some you know farm and you
know i
or whatever versus um you know a
multinational executive versus
everyone in between um there are
different kinds of of
impacts um so so yes that was that is
his style
i think history will ultimately look at
whether that
you know was effective or other styles
are more effective with respect to this
trade
um conversation conversation but
but i also think that in terms of
general diplomacy
there could have been a way to to do
that walk away
but do it in uh here's our plan
here here is kind of what we want to do
and actually have it more sort of
laid out and discussed as opposed to
walking away every time and coming back
and walking away and coming back
i think that's where um the weakness
came into play
all around the world from the from the
trade battles trade tariff battles
have you read the art of the deal um
i have not read the art of the deal oh
you haven't read his book it's a very
good book if you've not read the book
it's an excellent book so
let me let me ask uh another question
that has to do with china
so if we're negotiating with china and
um you know the president's talking to
you and the team is talking and they're
saying look
uh uh nomi you just brought up yourself
the currency manipulation
is what they do okay and you said that
they do currency manipulation but you
also said everybody else does it okay
fine
yeah let's just say everybody does it
but we know nothing about what they do
because they don't have free press
we have no idea what they're doing they
tell us what their unemployment is we
don't know who's reporting the
unemployment
it definitely cannot be 2.8 for the last
20 years
so the reporting of data there's no
integrity in it you're dealing with one
and a half billion people to see up on a
point of 2.8 percent
and there's currency manipulation there
is human rights challenges the data we
don't trust
a bunch of other things that we can get
okay you think it's fair to negotiate
and say
you know moving forward this is what we
would like we would like to see
you open up uh china
and allow facebook youtube twitter
uh linkedin all our social media
platforms to be there for your users
so we can feel more comfortable opening
up you know a business relationship with
you and lift some of these tariffs
because
through the media with our media
networks being on our social media
networks being there
all these facebook lives and videos we
can see how people are being treated
do you think that is a point to to
to put in there as for negotiation for
us to be able to see a little bit more
of
um transparency with their model and how
they're treating their business do you
think it's a fair uh
point to negotiate yes i do and as i
mentioned before i think one of the main
um issues with regarding trust um
we talked about you know so whether it's
the coronavirus or or sort of beyond
that
is um is that element of openness is is
that element
of information share you know which
which is better for example
obviously in india is is that idea of
that transparency because
um whether it allows us um to see what's
happening from a human perspective from
an individual perspective from a small
business a small business alliance
perspective say between the us
and and and actual you know people
running you know same forms of shops or
restaurants or or whatever
um in china i i do think that that that
is important
um you may um have have seen this in
your trips there but
um i find it for example i i continue to
find this interesting i just i just had
this conversation recently with with
someone who goes back and forth a lot
um is that in shanghai for example and i
can't speak to other
other areas um the hilton in shanghai
in particular um has a
sort of you know clubby thing at the top
and everybody sort of comes in whether
they're in textiles or
equipment or technology or
or programming or whatever and they all
sort of like hang out and they
communicate with each other and then
they sort of go their separate ways
and it's a very sort of
internationalized element and there
you can actually get on facebook and you
can actually google things
so it's like there's this and i don't
know if that's still the case this is
this was just in
in the recent couple of years but i did
find that odd because it was this there
was a separate
anti-fire wall sort of situation
in a particular area which was
particularly critical it was in shanghai
did you hear that um which i would not
have known had i not
physically been there
and i i mean
and and so there there there is a
capacity to perhaps do what needs to be
done when it when it has a very
particular business
um focused outcome perhaps
um then from the standpoint of the
overall country
um and so this was before tariffs this
was before
um i just was this was um this was when
i was writing collusion
so i would say this was um 216
217 probably 216 actually before the
election
but but the point the point being that
um
if you talk about transparency and the
sharing of communication platforms and
information
from that perspective i think it is
important in today's world period
um whether that is for business or for
humanity
um to have that open policy and to
request that open policy
and to have that open policy be a
criteria and potentially
for trade agreements exactly that's
that's the part and i don't know why
administrations in the past haven't
negotiated in that manner both on the
left and the right
they just kind of left china alone and
and the way
we left china alone we allow them to be
a superpower that they are right now
number two it was with the help of
america you take america out china
wouldn't be number two
uh china needed america to be number two
right now worldwide you know
i say this to you because yesterday an
article came out on business insider
talking about
fbi head i don't know if you saw this or
not fbi head calls
china the greatest long-term threat to
the u.s and alleges china plots to steal
us data and forcibly
repatriate its citizens and it goes
it goes into talking about the chinese
government is engaged in broad and
diverse campaign of theft and mala
malai malign influence and it can
execute the campaign
with authoritarian efficiency they're
calculating their persistent they're
patient and they're not the subject to
righteous constraints of an open
democratic society
or the rule of law so for me you know
i'm kind of glad pompeo
india shut down tick-tock you saw that
india had tick-tock there and you know
one young girl committed suicide and she
was a big tick tock star
india they just said let's shut down
tick tock because china was able to get
into it and pull up all your data like
if you use tick tock on your phone and
you leave it on china can go on your
phone and pull up any passwords and
anything they just said oh we're sorry
we didn't know
we had that and u.s has 180 million
users on tick tock and pompeo just said
yesterday
that they're considering banning tick
tock in us
which i believe it's a brilliant
strategy
because this adds to the point of you
want us to do business with china we'll
open up tick tock but you got to open up
facebook twitter all this other stuff
when it comes down to you so uh that was
a very good perspective you gave at
shanghai hilton but did you have a
rebuttal to that or respond to that no
no i i i agree that
that the idea of having a sort of clear
pro pro for
um the sharing of information platforms
the opening of information platforms i i
think it's um
i think it's a necessity today honestly
to have ultimately
um uh trustable trade relationships
agreements um and also for companies
doing business now it's not you know
international companies will be doing
business in and with china
so the more as they are right so so the
more that there's also this sort of
entire atmosphere of openness or at
least a more open atmosphere
um than there is now from the standpoint
of these platforms
um i think that just levels um that
whole field
and i think that with respect to china
growing as a superpower
relative to the us um i do think a lot
of that
i mean it did happen from the standpoint
of
what hurt us into the financial crisis
of 2008 and how they sort of capitalized
um and leveraged our system our monetary
system our banking system
in order to grow their um
alliances and um in retaliation kind of
to
our at that point in stability inside at
home
what what are the chances of trump and
his administration using the
crisis that took place with coronavirus
and blaming it on them to write off the
1.13 trillion dollars of debt that we
owe them and just say we're just not
going to pay you back this debt
uh what are the chances of that also
being used in the negotiation what are
your thoughts on that
so my thoughts on that are that over
over the years
um there's been a lot of back and forth
on
how much the people's bank of china how
much china owns the power of our
treasury treasury bonds our debt and
whether they will dump them from their
side you know so there's always been
that question you know can they do
something to us by dumping treasuries
can we do something by them by refusing
to pay
um which which you bring up so so both
sides of that equation
um i think um
might be discussed but the reality
situation is it would hurt us
to yeah to to not pay even if it's china
it doesn't matter
why because look at it as a full
portfolio treasuries
right we we have a you know 27 million
trillion dollar portfolio of treasuries
in the world
japan owns a piece china owns a piece
different central banks throughout the
world including the fed own a piece
individuals own a piece pension fund
zone a piece right
everyone has a piece of this portfolio
so just imagine you take out five or ten
percent of a portfolio
like that right you all of a sudden
basically do value
and this is the little price devaluation
i mean i'm not even talking about the
implicit guarantee or
the government guarantee of our treasury
bonds or anything like that i just mean
physical
yeah portfolio math um that all of a
sudden
you have a situation where you devalue
yourself
your own debt by
either not repaying debt and china that
was one of the reasons why
they didn't i think sell all their
treasury bonds they stopped buying as
many that's true
right so they already kind of tried to
play that but what they also tried to do
is look at their portfolio treasury
securities and say you know what
if we just dumped them like the world
was saying we might do
um that would devalue their portfolio it
would obviously devalue treasury bonds
but it would also devalue that it's the
same thing
for us if we decide to do anything that
calls into question even with whichever
country owns our treasuries
i personally think that that would be
detrimental to
our own debt which would make our debt
more expensive because there's so much
of it our public debt
which would make it harder for us to run
our budget and so forth because it only
takes five to ten percent of a portfolio
declining i mean to just smash like
the rest of it um from the standpoint of
pricing
it's a very different perspective it's a
very different perspective and i
appreciate that insight because it makes
you think about
but is there a way to say you know
return the shares or write it off
not versus not even wanting to do it you
know because if they do then on the
credit market our you know reputation is
hurt and it's going to hurt us to deal
with other nations when we have money
that we need etc etc because
china china's not even the biggest a
holder of our our bonds it's japan's
first place
china but like a hundred billion dollars
or 200 billion dollars right
i'm just curious to know if that's going
to be used or not you know
again i watch i you know how you
negotiate you have 20 different things
on the table
yeah and you say these seven things i
really want and these three things i'm
not willing to touch at all
and they say these eight things we
really want and these four things we
don't want to touch and you kind of but
you don't know that person's they don't
know yours
you're kind of assuming i wonder if
that's being used on the table by
either party to use it as a
motive and by the way china may even use
it to say look here's what we'll do you
all
we use this much money here's what we're
willing to do i don't know i'm just
thinking if they're the level of
creativity that's going to get to when
they negotiate
i i think that's that's interesting i i
i think you know whether it's on the
table or not and you know
it might be but but the reality is
china's effectively lent us money and we
either pay them back or don't right i
mean that's that's that's the sort of
you know scenario we're we're talking
about potentially but but
they they can choose not to lend us
money they can let their portfolio run
down
and that's actually that's actually
position of
power in terms of debt um holding
that they have relative to us because if
we say we won't pay it hurts us
more than if they run down their
portfolio and just don't buy more
treasuries which kind of has been what
they're doing as you say you know japan
has jumped ahead of china in terms of
who has the biggest book outside the us
actually the biggest book is
is the fed you know so years ago this
wasn't even like a thing
um so now basil the fed has the same
amount of treasuries as as
china and japan which kind of dilutes
their shares um if you will the
portfolio of treasuries
um so i i think it could potentially be
a tactic and it might even be something
that's thrown out
um and that you know financial media or
you know
discusses um and that could hurt or help
the treasury market depending on what
side and what day
um but right now um i think that it
would it would actually harm us
particularly with how we're
increasing our debt load into the
coronavirus pandemic after the financial
crisis and with the fed's balance sheet
you know just ballooning
um then i think it would um hurt them
so talking about a president who got the
bank to write off 900 million dollars of
his debt
so i'm just saying you know in his mind
if he treats everything as a business
and even his tactics of you don't want
to do this for us
25 tariff mexico doesn't want to do this
25 tariffs oh i'm gonna lift the tariffs
i'm sorry three days later all canada
oh i shouldn't have done that it's like
it's so shotgun you know
like uh it's it's uh but i'm just saying
assuming his reputation and his method
of negotiation in the past
i i uh you know to him it's only one
additional zero you know he's only
dealing with a couple zero additional
zeros he's not dealing that's the only
difference for him
he doesn't see it as anything more than
that i believe i may be wrong who knows
so
let's talk about fed let's talk about
the fed because you've spoken about the
fed before
and i've had daniel demartino booth here
i don't know if you're aware of hershey
okay and we've had other people that we
talked about the fed before
but you know one question for you is the
fed has always got a lot of
conspiracies tied to it right it's
always why it got started
who started it what was the motive
behind it you know the whole uh
jekyll island you know the whole jekyll
islands i don't know if you've read the
book or not maybe i don't know if that's
the book you've read or you haven't read
that one
so so i actually spent time at jekyll
island i i went through the actual
physical part of this whole deal we
finally figured this out
what happened to to actually see for
myself as i do
um when i do research um to talk to
their archivist and actually look at
uh one of the books that they have their
guest books now this is not conspiracy
that's just a fact
um and who signed them and who signed
them around 1910 when
uh the sort of origins of what became
the federal reserve act of 1913 were
discussed
um and i have read the jekyll island
book in fact i've also read all of the
um presidential archival papers from
woodrow wilson through taft and before
that um
and also from the morgan library when i
wrote all the president's bankers so so
and and part of that patrick part of
that was to
um to see for myself i didn't like i
wasn't born an
expert on the fed um you know i i wasn't
banking for for a long time the fed and
rates were in alan greenspan and waiting
for what he said was very important when
i was um
involved specifically working in in
investment banking
um but but to see what really happened
and um
whatever is said from a conspiracy
comparison conspiracy or not
uh the reality is that the fed was
created out of
necessity because there had been a panic
in 1907
in new york um and it was a situation
whereby the bankers were called upon
morgan and and a number of of key
bankers were called upon
to try and calm things down um by
theodore roosevelt who who otherwise was
a trust buster who otherwise didn't
trust you know big business um in
general
um but that was what was required um
between the president and the bankers at
that time
but what it created was an uncertainty
with among the bankers
as to how they could ultimately save
themselves in the next crisis
and and that was one of the impetuses
for figuring out how to have
a central bank a reserve of money
somewhere that could ultimately
um and they didn't use these terms these
are you know i'm putting today on
yesterday um but would be bailed out if
it was needed or have the markets be
liquefied um if it was needed
and that was one of the ways in which
the federal reserve ultimately
came into being when it came into being
in 1913 it didn't happen under roosevelt
didn't happen undertapped it happened
under wood wilson
um but it was a pretty bipartisan push
so it didn't really matter who was
president it was an issue of timing
um and that ultimately uh created from a
meeting that had happened in
at jekyll island in 1910 um to
the establishment of federal reserve
through that act in 1913 and
and the fed has most recently
um in the financial price of 2008 fast
forward about 100 years
um very much helped the markets
the banking system um and expanded its
capacity you know by trillions and
trillions of dollars
most recently in order to do that
so so uh so you went to jekyll island
and the six names the
nelson aldrich the uh the piazza andrew
henry davis and arthur shelton frank
van der lib paul warburg did you see all
of those names
there or no no no no let me go back
first of all there's a picture of all of
them there but that's that came later
and that's in the main hall
of the main eating area but now what i
saw
was morgan's actual signature as
someone who had been at jekyll island as
one of the club members so the way
jekyll island worked
um and and this i also got information
from their their their their historian
is the way that jackal island worked it
was a club it was sort of well as he
said it was kind of like the first
condominium for like
you know the equivalent of billionaires
at the time where they would go with
their families
predominantly over the end of the year
so like a thanksgiving christmas kind of
a period
um and there would be a tremendous like
count of
um you know sort of servants to
individuals they basically had all the
comforts that they would have sort of at
home but at jekyll island
they would close off the avenues to go
to jekyll island
um now there's a highway kind of
overhang but then there wasn't yet to
come by boat
they would put posts throughout the town
saying you know this is closed this is
the period people are going to be here
it's going to be closed and you have to
have a membership so henry hyde
the rockefellers um you know morgan this
is not spiritual
this this is this is in their history um
to to just
come to just physically walk onto that
property
um from your boat at the time um
and one of the things that happened at
the time was you you could have guests
but they had to be sponsored by
an individual who had a club membership
and so what happened at the time was the
the commonality
actually of jp morgan was with
aldrich um and aldridge's son actually
who was um
a new york banker at the time but who
wasn't involved in the in the
in the six people he just happened to
have been in new york that he he became
winthrop alger's became the head of
chase for
decades um but at that time he was not
um but the point is there was there was
that relationship and it was morgan that
actually just had the past
he wasn't there he wasn't involved he
was not physically at all
um at jekyll island at that time that
the origins of the fed were being
discussed but he was the name on the
book that was associated
with these individuals and so so that's
kind of how it
came down they would otherwise not have
been able to just get
physical access onto the onto the
property
it's like any now you know elite club
thing it's like
you invite people in or or they can't
come in
you're talking about six men apparently
that control the quarter of the wealth
of the world that's the data that you
hear about you know
so it's it's uh you you read about it
but again so
a lot of people said it was a spoof
about what the author wrote about him
and he said a lot of other things but
it's a story that picked up a lot of
attention on how the world wealth is
controlled by a few
handful of people how much do you buy
into that
well so these six people weren't weren't
necessarily all those people what
happened was like frank vanderlip who
was one of the people was
was a sort of vp a national citibank
which is now citigroup so i mean
there are different people that were
involved in the major banks at the time
so yes there was
an awful lot of money represented at
that meeting
and and nelson aldrich was the head of
what what we now consider the senate
finance committee
um and so he he was a very established
um senator and he had been going back
and forth to europe around this time
anyway to collect information um
for congress to create a central bank so
it wasn't like that yeah this was all
down to spur of the moment this was
something that was sort of
um being done um and sort of being
analyzed for a while but what happened
was he
um the plans the blueprint that was
created
um at jekyll island that was then
presented to congress
in 1910 and it was debated in congress
under taft and then
ultimately under woodrow wilson um those
blue pins were presented to congress and
this is in the congressional archives
this is not i mean this just happened
um and yeah i have the footnotes in my
book but i mean this was something
that's actually
occurred um two of the bankers actually
um presented the idea
to congress initially because nelson
aldrich actually
um had been ill for for various reasons
at the time or at least that was said at
the time in fact and this was in the new
york times at the time he had been hit
by a trolley car
if you can even imagine trolley cars
going down madison avenue
but before he went to jekyll island
according to new york times he he was
actually
in a trolley car situation i don't know
how badly he was hit the
article but the point is so anyway he
was he was convalescing throughout this
period
he did not because of that or other
reasons actually
initially present the plan to congress
it was presented by
um two of the bankers that were involved
um in those six people
so whatever said or not i said the the
the
the facts of the situation um was that
there were those people as we know
historically um in that room and as is
currently up at jekyll island which is
now
you know a regular resort it's been
converted over the years
um but the presentation of the initial
blueprint
for what became the federal reserve was
presented initially by two of those
people
and ultimately it was passed several
years later with
a lot of back and forth from multiple
bankers and
multiple senators and multiple house of
representative congress people
uh to figure out how they could um pass
it in such a way that was it was
palatable to sort of the electorate to
the country
um and by the way yeah sorry i'm sorry
go ahead
no i i can go on and on it's very
interesting so
the audience is going to be curious
about this so how much of what how much
of what is written in
the creatures of jekyll island is
accurate and how much of it is
conspiracy
well i i i think the accurate parts
um had to do with the the travel
um down to uh jekyll island and how it
was sort of done
i mean it it was done in in a way to
avoid publicity
of course publicity was different than
it is now it wasn't 24 7 it was
newspaper
we're totally different but so it was
easy it was easier to do that
but but the sort of clandestine way in
which you know the dead at night and all
that kind of stuff it's dramatic
it's kind of more dramatic in in in
terms of the telling of the story
um but that did happen in fact in frank
vanderlip's
um notes and and his family has a
foundation
foundation established um uh
library for basically his records and he
was a prolific writer he had been a
reporter actually before he
became a banker um i did the opposite
actually just i was a banker now a
reporter but the point is he um he
actually um as do
a number of those families have have
notes and records that they kept very
much for
sort of posterity there was a real sense
back then in particular in that part of
the country
and that part of our history um that
they felt themselves to be
bigger than themselves in that they had
to tell their state they wrote a lot
about what was happening
much more than um happens today
and so the story of going down and and
the people that went down
and and how it was done in a clandestine
manner was was
from vanderlip's own records now he
could have been embellishing it
that's entirely possible i don't know
that like you know he's
dead i yeah but um that i
that i don't know um and in terms of how
that book brought it up again it was it
was pr it was more dramatic than even
the dramatic telling of it by
someone who was a reporter slash writer
before he became a banker
um however the actual mechanics of the
story
um the sitting down the number of days
that they were there and he also wrote
about what they ate and all kinds of
stuff i mean
he has some very vanderlip not um
uh in his own notes um that that could
have been
for effect i i don't know um
but the the the actions that like
occurred out of it
and the documents that came back to
congress and the fights in congress
over the passage or not passage or what
it would look like and how it would go
down
that all is pretty much
at least from from my telling of it in
that i use the records themselves
um information that's accessible
to the public beyond the sort of more
larger story that has kind of grown up
around it
who do you know that knows as much about
the creatures of jekyll island as much
as you do
anybody have you met anybody no knows us
because you
really went in to find out everything
about it well so i i did this not just
on that i mean
my book and this is not but like all the
president's bankers was like my
like work for i i lived and breathed
these presidents
um from yeah library to library
of the presidents and also whoever
whatever historical event sort of
intersected their presidencies in this
case it was wilson
well from from roosevelt through wilson
um i don't know i i doubt bill grider's
book
um so the i think it's um i'm gonna
forget the name now but it's uh bill
grider was obviously
a major fed historian um as well
um and and he's he's written more um
about the combination of history and and
current um
well into mostly the alan greenspan days
um and so i've uh he was one of the
sources well he his book was one of the
non-publicly archival available
information sources for
drawing presence bankers um
so i in terms of the history
um those were probably the two main
books out there the two main authors
secrets of the temple how the federal
reserve runs the country
right so he has a section in there um
that goes into the history and that that
sort of period and how it was created in
the conversations um
that took place i specifically read all
of woodrow wilson's papers
so let me ask you this there's something
i read about what woodrow wilson wrote
and it's so interesting that you're
saying this because i got it right in
front of me
did he say this or did he not say this
based on the research that you did
he said this apparently in signing of
the federal reserve act in 1913 has
booked a new freedom back in 1916 he
said
i'm a most unhappy man i have
unwittingly ruined my country a great
industrial nation is controlled by its
systems of credit
our system of credit is concentrated the
growth of the nation therefore and all
of our activities are
in the hands of a few men we have come
to be one of the worst ruled one of the
most completely controlled and dominated
governments in the civil
civilized world no law no longer a
government by free opinion
no longer a government by conviction and
the vote of the majority
but a government by the opinion and
endures of a small group of dominant men
did he say this um so i
i can't verify word for word what what
he said
um but in terms of his papers
um what i found is that he said a
portion
of of what you read um and that
and that um in terms of the actual and i
could
probably turn around and get the quote
or send it to you um
but in terms of actually what he wrote
um or that was compiled
in the presidential library of woodrow
wilson it's not verified
however that doesn't mean it didn't
happen that he didn't say all of that
as as as that focus um
but it means that um it isn't
necessarily
captured in the papers that are in the
presidential
um combination of woodrow wilson's
um is it relatively close to what i read
meaning
sorry no i'm saying is it close is the
writing that you have is it close to
what i read
relatively close to the same beliefs it
is relatively close yes
wow so so he regretted the decision of
the federal
reserve the fed being put together he
he regretted the idea
of the federal reserve he didn't regret
that it was put together and i'll tell
you why
that distinction um just to be
sort of historical in in the wake of
world war one
so world war one begins he's in a
situation where he's running the country
trying to keep the us basically out of
world war one
in the beginning of it right um we're
we're a nascent country
trying to become our own power but like
way way
new in the whole game he actually
relied on the federal reserve and the
bankers
to work together when ultimately he was
pushed into or decided or however you
look at it
um going into that war um to
to basically help the allies um and and
part of that decision
was based on the reliance of the bankers
on the fed right they just created this
new thing
but they hadn't used it they hadn't
needed to use it he didn't need to use
it
right and all of a sudden we have
the need to raise money to
to be a part of a war or at least to
fund our allies the first thing we did
was fund our allies
not enter the war so the uk france and
and then we ultimately um were involved
to a later part of that war
so so in the beginning part he relied on
actually the morgan relationship just
because
it happened to have been involved in
financing just as
physical percentage-wise um of
war-related um activities
and then some other banks because of
war-related bonds that then people
bought to finance part of the war
um but but he did rely on it at that
point
um as the backstop for the banks
so i i mean i don't it he it could have
been
um a situation where he definitely
talked about being concerned about
having an elite group of bankers or
fed running the finances of the country
however also in a situation where
he believed it to be sort of expeditious
for
policy kind of didn't
so it's it's it's just it's just not
entirely black or white in that respect
i think he was a very intelligent
president he did things right he did
things wrong right as they all do
um but i think i think he weighed that i
don't know him this is just for my
readings
obviously um i think he weighed the
benefits
with the negatives um
as you know i asked the situation kind
of like presented itself
and war was a big situation that's kind
of like saying bezos
buffett gates you know uh ellison
a handful of these guys make all the
decisions in the world you know
it's the walmart family to be able to do
that but america's in so much debt that
america goes to billionaires to bail
them out and
and chase was a powerful man at that
time to be able to
you know can you imagine a person
bailing out a country and supporting out
that's that's a weird place to be to
have that kind of
wealth it well i mean 1893 1900 you know
you had you had
you had those families um you know
particularly the you know the mortgage
you had them have more money than the
government and we even when you talk
about basis on those guys today
you still have that balanced to
a very large book of treasury bonds in a
very
large um sort of economy we didn't have
that as a nation back then so
the power actually was quite more acute
back then
um because it was concentrated relative
to what the government had
in in a much much greater quantity i
mean you can't imagine president trump
calling up
well jamie dimon is saying can you loan
me out of like your personal money
um you have something to help me with
this whole china negotiation thing
right i mean it doesn't happen today
back then you know the the largest
trust buster you know from a
reputational perspective
and you know he's on mount rushmore
teddy roosevelt
had to he sent his treasury secretary to
do it but he had to ask morgan for for
help
so obviously it's a different time we
were not as powerful we were not as
thick we were not as strong we didn't
have the kind of revenues that we have
we didn't have even have the tax system
yet one of the first taxes was what
what year 1913 was in uh when we first
had our
1913 give or take so you're talking
about
there is no revenues coming in for him
to be able to do anything so
it makes sense it makes sense for the
richest people to be the people that you
got to go to to give you the money
do you think the fed did more good or
bad to america
over history or history over history
um well i i think over
history um the fed wasn't
though it was powerful it wasn't as
powerful as become recently so
it has done a disservice i think
recently
i.e the last really the century
uh more so because it's been the
backstop
um of what it considers to be liquidity
or part of its dual mandate of you know
achieving sort of price and
unemployment stability and
in doing so has created a real financial
hazard
um in terms of the cheaper rates and the
buying of right now every single type of
security
um and also doing that in the wake of
the financial crisis of 2008 so it's
it's taken out
i mean we talked about transparency
before um in a different manner it's
taken out sort of price transparency
from the markets and also
the drive to use capital um for the
purposes of more
infrastructure more production um
individuals employment growth
development and so forth because capital
by virtue of having been backstopped
its risk that the banks had you know
imbued upon us in financial crisis of
2008 before that
um going into this period um has been
backstopped by the fed
and what that's created is um ultimately
i think unstable environment where the
fed has to either continue to keep doing
what it's doing
in more magnitude um which it did this
coronavirus pandemic versus a financial
crisis
um or things are going to collapse and i
think in the history of the fed
there was more um external ups and downs
in the economy
but there was more of a sense if you
look at the you know post late 40s 50s
60s into the 70s there was
there was a sense of developing the
country whether that was from the
standpoint of you know highways
um of um infrastructure bridges
of roads of highways of hospitals that
time a lot of building was done in our
country
um in the middle of the last century and
that's because that's where capital
decided it could get a return
it was for other reasons too right but
but but from the standpoint we just
talked about sort of
you know capitalism and the fed's risk
and how that's destabilized the economy
which ultimately hurts
the population real people and crisis
disconnect
between the financial markets and the
real economy
i think it's been a negative it looks
good when there's a real crisis
at that moment to throw money at the
problem
but it doesn't actually sustain
the economy beneath that problem and it
doesn't
fix the economy not that it's a job but
it doesn't allow for the fixing
or the sustainable planning of the
economy
because of that so i think it's done
more harm than good
in this century and i think it's a
toss-up
um in parts of last century simply
because
other things were going on from an
economic growth perspective
that kind of competed with what the fed
was doing with respect to
at that point mostly interest rates
i think a lot of people are going to
agree with you on that i think many
people would
agree with you on that no matter what
side of the aisle they're on and
uh but we're at a point of no return
what can you do at this point meaning if
we wanted to
we're in too deep to do anything about
it to make a change right now
you know sometimes you talk to these
bigger companies and you say ig your
technology sucks you got to change it
take us four years to change it oh my
god i can't wait four years but we're
too big
we're so big it's not like a smaller
nimble company like when america was
smaller a little bit more nimble to make
changes
right a point of no return but who
who would hate the most if america
were to go back to gold standard who
would hate it the most who would say
absolutely not who would be against it
uh wall street the banking community
would be against it and and here's why
um and and i don't see us
for the record going back to a gold
standard or
um yeah just i just don't see that
because of this or among other
because of this because the banking
community having
established a reliance on the ability to
have
our currency created when it's needed
fed can grow its books that can move the
level of our currency up and down
um so there is that symbiotic
relationship between wall street the
major bankers major financial
institutions and the fed
it's most tight between those
two groups than it is between you know
facebook and the fed or google and the
fed you know there's a very there's a
very strong relationship between those
two
and the reason um that in the 70s
there was such a push to get off of the
gold standard
uh among other things and this you know
this this is something that
was building from um what had happened
in 1933 but then we went back back on we
went back off is that the banking
community back then
i also have this uh the banking
community back then really pushed nixon
who ultimately did it um
but really pushed him to reconsider
having a gold standard
and one of the reasons in other words to
get off it um and one of the reasons for
that was that they couldn't really
um grow and expand from their own
capital perspectives
with their own backstop the fed or just
the
idea of moving money in general if it
was tied down if it was tied to
something physical if it was
tied to something that other nations
other actors
had more or as much control of
as they did and so the idea of floating
off of it
and the idea of having solely a currency
based on
sort of a fiat nature to a currency is
actually very palatable
if as a bank you have a call on that
currency
and with gold it would be gold was more
constraining
and i think gold would be more
um and i think that's something that
actually presidents have said on on both
sides
since then ben bernanke as the head of
the fed
was very much against the concept even
it was brought up in the wake of the
financial crisis because gold was going
up
the dollar was sort of hobbling along
things were sort of crippled
um he he went on record in front of
congress and
and defended the even the possibility
of returning uh to a gold standard i
mean sort of so did um
the obama administration i mean this was
some but it's more because of the
banking community
um that would hate it the most let me
ask you
if we are on the gold standard is
quantitative easing
possible it's much harder for that same
reason
is it possible it's possible if we're
not 100
on the gold standard right because you
have that leeway
let's just say if we are 100 it's not
possible right
it's not possible you can't create gold
right so you can't you can't
elasticize gold or the relationship of
gold to your currency
because you can't you can't create it
yeah it keeps a nation disciplined
though i mean it's a
do you think the right thing is to be on
gold standard is that the responsible
right thing for the future of a nation
i i think simply being on the gold
standard today
given the sort of globalized nature of
today in currencies and sort of where
they interact
um i think would be it would just be
difficult to actually
achieve i do think a portion if we
looked at sort of composite currencies
i think a portion of gold um is useful
in restraining that sort of we can grow
a balance sheet as much as we want
we will be here to buy all your
mortgage-backed securities your
asset-backed securities your commercial
yeah
we will we can't have that um
it would act i think as as a way to
contain
that sort of balance sheet blow up and
qe
which i think would ultimately be better
because it would force
um sort of economic decisions that are
based on real capital being available
right now
as opposed to manufacture capital
being available for markets whenever
are you are you someone who studied the
uh j you sound like when you go into
topics and you're uh obsessed about it
you fully go study everything
are you someone that ever got any uh
interest in the jfk assassination or not
at all that wasn't something that
intrigued you much
um it's interesting i do i do cover um
in in on the president's bankers his his
assassination but not from this not not
in a sort of deep dive i i more looked
at
um his relationships to to the banking
community
um to to what he said with respect to
latin americans and opening the country
borders and everything else and so i i
didn't
um yeah i don't it's not my area
okay yeah i'm just curious you know if
you went into um
the the people who were not happy about
the direction he wanted to go with fed
and
gold and all that and they were not i
did look at the one
um comment about um that because there
was such a
because there's so much out there
there's so much sort of inquiry over
over the concept of you know was it the
fed was the goal was
that he wanted a direction um but but
sort of in
an unlimited um
way um so i i again i can't really um
fair enough so we're not gonna i thought
we were gonna figure that out today know
me i was i was hoping the world wouldn't
do that today i was on the grassy knoll
though i i got us
i was there because i was looking up you
know sort of the possibility of but it
just didn't fit into the overall
structure of and it was a black hole it
would have been a very deep black hole
it would have never been
very literally never finished i agree
with you yeah
i've probably interviewed 15 mario how
many people have we interviewed on the
topic of jfk assassination i don't know
i mean from people who held the brain in
the autopsy room
clint hill his secret service the you
know agent but
it's a black hole that'll last a
lifetime and we had robert f kennedy his
uh yeah kennedy jr on and i asked him
about how much investigation he did he
said he wrote a book about it and he
really went down the
rabbit hole if you've not seen that
interview the last 30 minutes is very
interesting so
final thing here topic to touch up
before we go into the speed round
is europe yourself do you consider
yourself
a capitalist would you say you're a
capitalist you believe in capitalism
i believe in uh fair capitalism
do you believe in socialism i also
believe in democratic socialism
so what do you think is too much taxes
to so
so i ask the question more with numbers
so you're a data person and
and i've looked at this a lot i'm
curious to know what you're going to say
let's take a side capitalism and let's
take us out socialism let's not give it
any labels
let me ask this question i make a
hundred thousand dollars a year how much
money is too much for me to pay the
government in taxes
what should what should the ban be i i
think that depends on where you live
making that money
um for one thing so your hundred
thousand dollars in new york versus your
hundred thousand dollars um
taxes just look at it from a federal tax
standpoint don't don't break it down
with state so
state california thirteen three uh if
i'm in tennessee
zero if i'm in texas zero florida zero
just assume federal i make a hundred
thousand dollars a year
how much is too much taxes for me to
hand over to the government for the hard
work that i put in how much is too much
of that full hundred um again it depends
what you get back for
given what we get back for it um here
um i think the 33 40 percent level is is
fair
okay but so thousand dollars
that's on a hundred thousand dollars so
so that's not a hundred thousand okay
how about a million dollars
i think i i think on a million dollars i
i think there could be i
i agree with a sort of proportional um
tax
percentage on that um so
if i say 33 in a third or 40 is a max
for
a hundred thousand dollars um i could
see that as like the first hundred
thousand dollars
um and then sort of a gradient in a
slightly lower
direction get up to the million but but
still taxing
you know that is a proportional amount
so up to a hundred thousand dollars 33
and a half percent okay
up to quarter million dollars let's just
say you're saying 40 percent
if i'm making million up uh what should
be my taxes a million up
well again i think you just do that same
forty percent or whatever whatever the
grid is
okay fair enough yeah
three and a half all the way up to forty
right fair okay so
okay so then the states the state you're
in the state i used to be in
you're in california i'm in texas now
your state is 13-3
do you think that's too much to be
living in a state of california
um well there are certainly taxes in
california i
um i i do pay them a lot of them
um but i also think um
one of the things california does which
other states don't do quite as much is
it sort of does referendum out the
things that people
have to spend their taxes the things
that um
are voting and people can vote on to
basically decide where their taxes go
yeah this reference on the ballot right
it's kind of the equivalent of
so it's like if i'm getting stuff for
my marginal proportion or additional
proportion
of taxes um i think that's
and a state does that well or nation
does that well if you sort of move out
of california
um i i think that's a good thing um
and so at a certain level of of earning
um it's not as necessary but for sort of
individuals on the ground
where you know there's health concerns
there's education concerns there's
there's
you know safety concerns all of that i
think money needs to come into
the system to be able to sort of make it
um run california is taking that to a
whole different level and they're losing
a lot of people especially the younger
hungry people not the people that
already made their money because
there's a different story between your
money-making years
versus you deciding to make your money
to a place for instance i was in monaco
for a 10-year anniversary my wife and i
we went there
and you know they they're the popular
the city is smaller than central park
right
and the life expectancy in monaco is the
highest in the world people live
89 years yeah this is after they made
their 100 million dollars and they
moved to monaco that's different you
don't see a 22 year old saying i'm going
to go make my money in monaco
right they're going to go to a different
place as a money-making
years of your life 25 to whatever the
number is going to be 55 let's just say
where you're willing to play offense and
go out there and work the 12 16 hour
days
do you think it's fair the kind of taxes
a state like california is passing down
to its people
um again i i think for the people just
starting out and the people making less
um that i would equate you know
sort of lower that tax relative to
people making more the people you're
talking about who have more
um who um who have more
to be taxed um than someone just coming
in i mean i started out in new york city
um where like my entire paycheck went
yeah i mean obviously i started out
chase as an analyst i mean my paycheck
basically went to taxes and my rent and
that was that was like it
um so so so i do think that it does
matter like you say you know whether
you're coming in early
um in your in your life in your career
in your money-making situation or if
you're
someone who works on tips or if you're
someone who works multiple jobs if
you're someone who works gig
jobs um that i do think um
it's it's better to have a lower tax
rate for for those people to get them
into the economy and to help them build
that sort of stability
relative to people who who have made
more or or have more that's what i was
talking about in terms of a proportional
uh sort of taxing because because that
that makes them stay
um and it also brings a foundational
kind of economic stability to those
those people and therefore
yeah ultimately it goes forward into the
revenues of
a state of a city like la
um if you have the people at the bottom
you know able to move
well i mean i you know it's it's
interesting you say that i agree with
that when i lived in l.a
and i would go down that 405 every day i
would sit i'm like okay let me get this
here what the hell am i doing spending
two hours a day on the freaking 405
freeway
i landed one night one day at 3 30 i
wanted to go from lax to rafi's place to
eat
it's 18 miles it took two and a half
hours to go there i would not
what am i doing to go two and a half
hours
and 18 20 miles to go to a restaurant so
and i moved to texas and i had a guy
sitting next to me who
was a socialist he's not a capitalist
and we were driving
and he says man i don't like the fact
that we have to pay the toll here in
texas
i said well the way texas works is you
don't pay state taxes
if you don't want to use the toll then
don't use it take the streets you don't
have to pay the tax
but in texas you pay taxes for things
you use
in california you pay for things you'll
never use like they had an express road
here in texas dallas and i would
pay the money to go through this express
but there's only two cars and i'm like
i'll pay this no problem i'm able to go
past 300 cars
i never saw that in california so when
you're talking about and by the way this
is a man that left california at 37
years old prime money making yours and
i'm going to be making money for another
20 30 years
and that could they could have gotten a
lot of those taxes but they they abused
it and i'm seeing a massive exodus with
a lot of younger other people that
relate to what i'm saying
so going back to you said you you're
you're believing fair capitalism i think
that's the word used i don't want to put
words in your mouth i think you said
fair capitalism and you believe in
democratic socialism
socialist socialism which is an element
of what bernie talks about
but bernie also talks about 70 and you
were supportive of bernie i think you
guys did some work together he relied on
some of the economic stuff
what are your thoughts when we're
talking about 70 of taxes and just
bashing rich people the top one percent
of america they're just so
this and they're doing this and they're
doing oh my gosh you feel guilty to talk
about the fact that you make some money
it used to be a time people admired
successful people i mean you're somebody
that's made millions of dollars you're
somebody that's very successful you're
somebody that
essentially is top one percent if you
work that goldman sachs as a
top person you are one percent what's
wrong with going to the one percent and
here's the thing i don't want to be in a
bernie bash moment because i i truly
believe a bernie against the trump stood
a better chance than a biting against
the trump
because at least you know what bernie
stands and that's one of the things i
respect about bernie
bernie's bernie you don't know where
biden's at when i looked at bernie i'm
like you know what
it doesn't matter if i disagree with
this guy i respect the guy that has
his own ways of fixing things and he
doesn't flip-flop and i would have loved
to see
those two guys going at it but
unfortunately i don't think we're ever
going to see that although it would have
been incredible debates
people would have tuned into so going
back to it
i watch you i watch your videos and i've
watched your interview with bernie that
you guys said i think in 2013 or 2016. i
don't know what it was it was many many
nine 2009 i watched that as well i
watched a lot of your work
you seem very reasonable you seem fair
you seem like you're able to stay in the
middle and kind of uh hear both sides of
the argument out
how does someone like you as reasonable
you are get behind
70 for rich people
so um the work i did with bernie was
mostly on the fed and
and the idea of um and on wall street so
the idea of basically creating
going back to fairness um you know sort
of an auditing path a transparency path
seeing what the fed was doing where it
went who's getting the most benefit
um and this ties in and also from the
standpoint of wall street banks
um to what extent were they basically
creating securities and
um you know that was hiding or the risk
that ultimately
we had all seen in the economy and the
financial system which i believe
still exists um it's been papered over
the fed's thrown money at it so it's
deeper in the system but but it's there
and i think that yeah so that's what i'm
talking about when i talk about a fair
um environment from the standpoint of 70
for um of all of rich
people um you know if you if you take
someone and you know
wherever you calibrate that number and
you say
70 of all of your income
is is gone um i i do that from an income
from standpoint not a wealth for
standpoint i think that's that's very
high
from a gradient which is which is where
i i i would disagree with an absolute
level
like that um what what i'm saying is
that there
should be some sort of a gradient um
between
someone more wealthy paying more of the
initial part of their income
relative to you know sort of a number
that that that is that high so it
becomes proportional
you're not paying 70 percent i don't
believe um it's necessary to pay 70
percent of your income
but i'll say this too i think companies
should pay more in taxes to avoid some
of these situations in terms of getting
money into
the budget of our country into reducing
the deficit of our country which of
course now has grown because of the
virus and
and it does grow because of different
crises um i i think that
rather than not paying taxes into the
revenue of the treasury department
which right now companies pay about 10
to 13 of the full
amount of revenue that goes into the
into our coffers as a nation
um it used to be much higher than that
there's maybe a happy media
but because they're not paying as much
just mathematically there's a greater
amount to be covered in order to run
the country and if there's a greater
amount to be covered in order to run the
country and it's not coming from growth
um which i think would be the better way
to do it and talk about economic growth
earlier then having a proportional tax
system
allows some of that to be
retrieved not not not all of it not
making up for for companies not putting
as much in
and not necessarily going to that
absolute level for
everyone who is wealthy in terms of
their income
um but i do think there's there's
there's there's a give and take there
i think that's a high number i i don't i
don't um
but but i also think that we have to as
a nation use that money whatever it is
um for things that actually sustain
economic growth
and companies and individuals and rich
people could be doing that it's not to
say that that's not happening
but but to the extent that taxes are
taken out they should give benefit
to the overall country and the overall
growth of our country and i think that
helps both the people at the bottom
um as well as those who are wealthier
because you just you just have better
roads like it doesn't take it might take
you two and a half hours to go anywhere
once coronavirus is over out of la to
anywhere else that could still happen
but but the idea is that you have a more
efficient system whether it's
technological or infrastructure wise
because money's going into
things that everyone dreams not just
rich not just poor but
all of us and you think governments are
being efficient right now with work
with our taxes no no no no so why would
why would taxpayers why would taxpayers
feel confident constantly paying more
taxes
while the government can go out there
and print money and quantitative easing
give it to
whoever they want and i'm sitting here
working my ass off
making 80 grand a year 100 to whoever it
is 150 000
a year i'm barely seeing my kids and i'm
seeing them being built up but i have to
pay
50 percent of my taxes to you and i'm
not seeing the roads getting better i'm
not seeing streets getting better
i i have a very hard time with that
exactly the point
that's exactly the point the the fact is
we shouldn't pay taxes into this massive
quantitative easing
money creation into just sort of a
market perspective rather than building
the roads or
or or having faster trains or whatever
it might be or having better hospitals
or more or more efficient
you know testing system now or whatever
it might be um yeah i absolutely i
i totally agree with that we we have
mismanaged
the the creation of money let alone our
taxes
because of well because we mismanaged
both
effectively um but but throwing the qe
into it throwing the federal reserve's
balance sheet into it throwing that
massive inflation of of just the
availability of cheap money that doesn't
go into doing anything
i mean you know i don't even have i
don't even see lines on the 101 when i
get out of la and they're they're not
they don't paint them they're old you
can't you just make up your own lanes
that's the point though
why why are they paying 13.3
and here's the thing though because look
i was telling you earlier
i lived there 24 years and we're looking
at four other places to go
live and we were looking to go back to
you know
somewhere around what is that the place
right by
agora hills it's right outside of agora
hills it's a nice area
we're looking at there we're looking at
malibu we're looking at uh
newport right we want to go back to la
i'm like my friends are there everything
i know is la 24 years from 12 years old
to 37 mla minus me being in the military
we looked at greenwich we looked at
florida we looked at uh uh
uh texas california went from first
place to last place
in no time because they keep saying pay
more taxes
gas tax this tax and california's like
okay
how many more things you're going to
keep raising and nothing is getting
better so
a question for you who are you
comfortable
having more power people government
or companies in order if you were to say
one two three what would you say
i would say people companies and
government
we're on the same page okay we're on the
same page so we you know
i feel like i can talk to you for hours
i'm really enjoying this you know i
thought this was going to be an hour
interview
and we're already i told you i said it's
going to be an hour because i have
meetings i'm like i'm already
hour and 45 minutes we've been together
because i'm having a blast with you
i respect the way you reason uh and
process issues it's very uh
it's very trusting the way you process
issues you know i
uh i can't say that about everybody but
i can say that definitely about you and
i i appreciate that let's do a quick
speed round i'll give you a name tell me
the first thing that comes to your mind
and if you don't have anything to say
about it just have nothing to say about
it we'll be fine as well
uh bernie sanders better against trump
uh milton friedman uh we don't have free
markets anymore
biden um kind of not clear on his
policies
fair enough karl marx uh
not great for women but have some
okay all right barack obama diplomatic
i agree trump
major i think that's a fair assessment
uh richard wolff um
[Music]
academic safe safe
arthur laffer i know but he is he's also
an academic that just came to my mind
arthur laffer don't know okay
uh alan greenspan out of his league
her heart did her risk because of
derivatives
frederick hayek don't know
okay ludwig von mises
libertarian interesting
i'll finish with that one um first of
all
i really enjoyed our time together
thank you so much for making the time to
be a guest and took all the questions
that we went
together with very very good perspective
i'm
certain the audience enjoyed the
interviews just as much as i did
and once again thank you for taking the
time and being a guest on valuetainment
thank you so much for having me on
patrick be well anyway
thank you bye-bye bye-bye i've had a lot
of different economists and folks that
are in the financial world that have
their own opinions but this one was
slightly different i'm curious your
thoughts about what she said regarding
china india iran that connection there
and then the topic with the creature of
jekyll island the amount of research she
had done i've never interviewed anybody
that knew this much about the creatures
of jekyll island
and how jp morgan funded world war one
when dealing with teddy roosevelt
and some of the things that i had handy
there with woodrow wilson what were your
thoughts about that and last but not
least
uh when i shared my sentiment about
california and taxes
and you heard what she said about it she
worked closely with bernie sanders but
she had some stuff to say about taxes i
want to hear your thoughts
on those topics and outside of that i
got two interviews if you enjoyed this
interview
i have two other interviews i want you
to watch one of them is with the
nine-year
uh dallas federal reserve expert who is
who talks on tv all the time about
finance if you've never watched my
interview with daniel demartino booth
it's an incredible interview
click over here and the other one is
someone that i asked her about where
i said what do you think about richard
wolff and she said
academic and i said safe answer and she
laughed if you've not watched this one
this one got heated but it was a
friendly debate
click over here to watch this and if
you've not subscribed to the channel
please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye